Hoy es un día de lluvia en el don vas y
esto a pesar de las dificultades el
clima el barro que hay en la mayoría de
las carreteras venimos de uno de los
frentes en el norte en el frente de
criminal y es batovia y se podía ver la
dificultad entre el agua y la nieve que
empieza a derretirse Pero también es un
día de cierta tranquilidad para las
tropas en el frente porque los drones no
pueden hacer su trabajo de identificar
posiciones en una región donde la
situación es cada vez más difícil lo que
está pasando en los últimos días o en
las últimas semanas es esa
intensificación del número de tropas
rusas de diferentes organismos incluidos
los paramilitares wagners que tratan en
gran número de romper las líneas de
Ucrania luego cuando los detienen
vuelven otras líneas detrás Y así uno
tras otro tratando de encontrar los
puntos débiles y esto Es evidente en
esta ciudad del backwood estamos en
kramators está a menos de una hora de
aquí y allí la situación es cada vez más
complicada las tropas rusas tratan de
encerrar y encerrar el centro de la
ciudad tratan de rodearla incluso la
población cercana de chasiblar que se
había convertido como en ese pulmón de
bakmut también es cada vez más asediada
y la carretera que lleva hacia esta
población es constantemente atacada Así
que es mucho más difícil para las no
solamente para las abastecimientos del
ejército sino también para la ayuda
humanitaria que trata de dar apoyo a las
6000 personas que permanecen actualmente
en Back mood y esto también crea cierto
nerviosismo en otras partes del Don vas
especialmente en estas dos grandes
ciudades de kramators y estudiantes
porque se preguntan cuánto tiempo más va
a resistir el presidente se les que ha
dicho que la situación es bastante
difícil y que ellos intentarán resistir
pero la medida en que puedan y muchos
piensan que posiblemente
el momento en que empiecen una retirada
Para no perder más hombres de los que ya
se han perdido no solamente muertos sino
el número de heridos que esto ha sido
incluso aún más grande para los rusos
Pero ellos tienen muchísimo más gente
que los uc